Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Marc:
I LIKE THAT CONFIDENCE.
Tyra: NEW YORK'S
TOP DESIGNERS
LIKE MARC BOUWER
PUT THE GIRLS TO THE TEST...
Marc: WHOOPS.
Man: SHE WAS BUSTING OUT
OF THAT JACKET.
Woman:
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
Tyra: PLUS-SIZED TOCCARA
STRUGGLED
TO BREAK BARRIERS...
Toccara: I'M JUST TRYING TO
STAY POSITIVE, AND IT'S HARD.
Janice: HELLO.
Nigel: THERE'S NO REASON
WHY YOU SHOULDN'T BE TAKING
PHOTOGRAPHS LIKE THIS
ALL THE TIME.
Tyra:
ANN PROVED TO THE JUDGES
THAT SHE'S MORE THAN JUST
A PRETTY FACE...
THANKS, CASSIE.
BUT IN THE END,
CASSIE WAS SENT HOME.
SEVEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED
TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Tyra: MA, THERE'S A GIRL
THAT, UM, WE ELIMINATED
LAST NIGHT.
HER NAME IS CASSIE.
IT WAS BETWEEN CASSIE
AND TOCCARA,
WHO'S LIKE
A FULL-FIGURED GIRL.
THE JUDGES WERE, LIKE,
GOING BACK AND FORTH.
IT WAS REALLY, REALLY CRAZY,
BUT IN THE END,
CASSIE WAS VOTED
TO GO HOME.
AND IT'S KIND OF HARD FOR ME
BECAUSE SHE CONFESSED
TO ME THAT SHE'S BULIMIC.
Carolyn: HMM.
Tyra: AND I TRIED
TO GET HER HELP...
Cassie: YOU CAN TELL ME I
SHOULDN'T DO THAT ALL YOU WANT,
BUT IF I FEEL LIKE
I'M STILL GONNA DO IT,
I'M NEVER GONNA BE HELPED.
Tyra: AND SHE WAS, LIKE,
"I DON'T LIKE THERAPISTS,
I DON'T WANT TO GO, AND I'M
NOT GONNA STOP DOING THIS,
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER."
AND I JUST FEEL LIKE,
YOU KNOW,
LIKE, WHAT ELSE CAN I DO?
Carolyn: IT'S NOT LIKE
YOU THREW HER AWAY, TYRA.
YOU CAN ONLY DO SO MUCH
TO HELP A PERSON
THAT IS BASICALLY LOST.
SHE HAS TO FIND HERSELF.
SHE NEEDS TO DO
SOME SOUL-SEARCHING.
SHE NEEDS TO LOOK WITHIN
TO FIND THE STRENGTH
TO GET THE HELP THAT SHE NEEDS.
Tyra: RIGHT.
Carolyn: SO IT'S OKAY.
♪♪♪
Toccara: LAST ELIMINATION,
SOMEONE ON THE PANEL
SAYS...
Nolé: AMERICA IS NOT READY
TO SEE A PLUS-SIZED TOP MODEL.
Toccara:
I'M LIKE, "WHOA." PFFT.
MY MISSION HERE
IS TO BREAK THE NORM
AND LET YOU KNOW THAT BIG GIRLS
CAN DO HIGH FASHION, TOO.
Eva:
YOU KNOW HOW FATTENING
THESE BEAN AND CHEESE
BURRITOS ARE?
- Yaya: NO.
- Ann: WHOSE IS THIS?
Eva: IT'S FOR YOU. GO AHEAD.
PUT SOME CHEESE ON THAT.
(Spanish accent)
AND DON'T BE STINGY, OKAY?
Ann: OH, STOP IT,
NOT TODAY, PLEASE.
Eva: A LOT OF THE OTHER GIRLS
SEE ME AS LOUD AND CRAZY.
BUT I HAVE FEELINGS.
I HAVE EMOTIONS. I HAVE LAYERS.
LIKE, ONE PERSON ISN'T
THE SAME ALL THE TIME.
BUT THIS IS A COMPETITION,
AND SO ALL MY GUARDS ARE UP.
Ann: THESE ARE ACTUALLY
SURPRISINGLY GOOD FOR YOU.
LIKE, THERE'S HARDLY
ANY CARBOHYDRATES IN THESE.
Yaya: CARBOHYDRATES,
SCHMARBOHYDRATES.
I DEFINITELY COME
FROM A DIFFERENT PLACE
THAN OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE HOUSE.
Ann: (belches)
Yaya: I'M NOT
JUST GETTING SWEPT UP
IN THIS SUPERFICIAL
WORLD.
DO YOU EVER THINK THAT
THIS LOW CARB FASCINATION
IS A GIMMICK?
Ann: YAYA HAS HER LITTLE
BITCHY, LIKE, ATTITUDE.
SHE THINKS
SHE KNOWS EVERYTHING.
Yaya: LOOK, SERIOUSLY,
ALL THIS TALK ABOUT LOW CARB
THINGS IS REALLY ANNOYING.
(knock on door)
Ann: I WAS THE FIRST ONE
TO HEAR A KNOCK ON THE DOOR.
Woman: HI, HOW ARE YOU?
Ann:
I'M GOOD. HOW ARE YOU?
Woman: GOOD, THANK YOU.
Ann: AND I'M LIKE,
"AM I SUPPOSED TO KNOW
WHO THESE PEOPLE ARE?"
Rebecca: MY NAME IS
REBECCA WEINBERG.
I'M A STYLIST--
AN EMMY AWARD-WINNING STYLIST.
Paul:
AND I'M PAUL WILMOT,
AND WE HAVE A PUBLIC RELATIONS
COMPANY IN NEW YORK
CALLED PAUL WILMOT
COMMUNICATIONS.
I'M WITH MY COLLEAGUE
HAMPTON CARNEY TODAY.
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO IS
WE'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU
A BIT OF A TUTORIAL
TODAY ABOUT IMAGE.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU SOME TIPS
ON EVENTS AND SO ON.
AND THE SAME TIME YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SIT WITH REBECCA,
AND SHE'S GONNA GO
THROUGH A CLOSET WITH YOU
AND REALLY HELP YOU
CREATE YOUR LOOK.
AND SHE'LL MAKE
SOME SUGGESTIONS.
HAMPTON AND I ARE GONNA
START WITH YAYA.
Rebecca: AND I'M GONNA
TAKE AMANDA.
Hampton: COOL.
Yaya: I AM A VERY WORLDLY
INDIVIDUAL.
I JUST GRADUATED FROM
AN IVY LEAGUE UNIVERSITY,
AND I FEEL LIKE I CAN
TALK TO PEOPLE
ABOUT ALMOST ANYTHING.
I'M JUST NOT SURE WHAT KIND
OF CONVERSATION
IS APPROPRIATE
IN THIS WORLD.
Hampton: NEVER THINK THAT
YOU KNOW ALL THE ANSWERS.
'CAUSE PEOPLE
WILL LIKE YOU BETTER.
AND I THINK YOU CAN TAKE IT
REALLY FAR THAT WAY.
Rebecca: PICK OUT
YOUR FAVORITE FIVE THINGS.
I JUST KINDA WANNA GET
AN IDEA OF WHO YOU ARE.
Amanda: MM-HMM.
Rebecca:
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO SAY
WHEN I LOOK AT THESE THINGS,
THEY LOOK A LITTLE CHEAP.
Amanda: I'M VERY POOR.
Rebecca: ALL RIGHT, BUT
THE IDEA IS TO TAKE SOMETHING
THAT'S INEXPENSIVE AND KIND OF,
LIKE, TWIST IT
AND MAKE IT LOOK
MORE THAN IT IS.
Eva:
WHY AM I EVA THE DIVA?
Paul: YOU LOVE IT.
Eva: EVERYBODY FREAKIN'
SAYS TO ME THAT I AM A DIVA.
SO HOW DO I NOT BE A DIVA?
Paul:
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
BY SHOWING THE BEST
POSSIBLE MANNERS
TO PROVE THAT UNDERNEATH
ALL THAT IS A REALLY--
A VERY GOLDEN PERSON,
A VERY NICE PERSON.
Rebecca:
VERY EARTH MOTHER.
Yaya: I WOULDN'T MIND
STICKING TO THAT STYLE.
Rebecca: THAT STYLE?
BUT IT'S FINE TO STICK
TO A STYLE.
BUT IT'S ALSO--IT'S LIKE,
IF YOU GO TO A TOOTHPASTE AD,
ARE YOU GONNA GO
IN A DASHIKI?
OR ARE YOU GONNA, LIKE,
GO IN A T-SHIRT AND JEANS?
Yaya: IN ORDER
TO BE SUCCESSFUL,
I DON'T HAVE TO CONFORM
TO THESE CONSTRAINTS.
Rebecca: STEREOTYPES.
I SEE THIS IN GENERAL,
BUT WHEN I SEE YOU
PULL OUT THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS, I SEE NO VARIETY.
MIX IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
MAYBE BY ADDING
A LITTLE COLOR?
IT'S LIKE,
"I'M THE HAPPY YAYA."
Paul: TELL ME ABOUT YOU.
Ann: I'M NOT THE MOST PROPER
ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
Hampton: EVEN IF YOU'RE
GONNA SAY SOMETHING
THAT MAY BE NAUGHTY OR
SOMETHING, SAY IT INTELLIGENTLY.
Rebecca: I SEE A LOT OF, LIKE,
TRENDY STUFF GOING ON HERE.
SO IT'S EASY.
IT'S LIKE THROWAWAY CLOTHES.
Toccara: MY CLOTHES
ARE FABULOUS, REBECCA.
Rebecca:
YOU'RE B.S.-ING ME.
TOCCARA LACKS A LITTLE BIT
OF PERSONAL STYLE.
I DON'T SEE ANYTHING REALLY
DRESSY TO PULL ANYTHING
OUT OF YOUR CLOSET
THAT'S LIKE, "WOW."
WHEN I LOOK AT YOU, YOU'RE JUST
LIKE ECLECTIC COMFORTABLE.
Eva: MM-HMM.
Rebecca: EVA NEEDS
TO BROADEN HER HORIZONS.
THESE ARE OKAY, BUT THEY
DON'T SAY MUCH.
I'D LIKE TO SEE EVA OWN UP
TO HER POTENTIAL STARDOM.
I WANNA SEE EVA IN SOMETHING
THAT NOBODY ELSE HAS.
Eva: OKAY.
Amanda: I'M PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST UNIQUE GIRLS HERE.
I'M LEGALLY BLIND.
Paul: YOU HAVE A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN
SIMILAR SITUATIONS
TO BECOME, YOU KNOW,
AN EMBLEM FOR SUCCESS.
Rebecca:
THIS IS LIKE SO HIGH SCHOOL.
GIRL, YOU GOTTA GROW UP.
NORELLE'S STYLE--
IT'S SO YOUTHFUL,
THAT IT'S CHILDLIKE.
I DON'T SEE ANYTHING HERE
THAT SAYS,
"I CAN BE
A SOPHISTICATED WOMAN."
Nicole: I LIKE ART.
I LIKE STUFF
THAT'S NOT REALLY NORMAL.
IT'S NOT REALLY
POP CULTURE.
I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S GONNA BE A PROBLEM
WHERE I HAVE TO, LIKE,
ACT LIKE
I LIKE JESSICA SIMPSON
OR SOMETHING. EVEN LIKE--
Hampton: IF YOU ARE ASKED
A QUESTION ABOUT POP CULTURE,
YOU CAN ANSWER
THAT QUESTION
THAT'S TRUE TO YOURSELF,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
YOU'RE NOT BEING SORT OF A JERK
IN FRONT OF A REPORTER.
Paul: NO NEGATIVES.
Rebecca: YOU'RE KIND OF
A LITTLE BIT COUNTRY
AND A LITTLE BIT
ROCK 'N' ROLL.
Ann:
OH, I HAVE EVERYTHING.
Rebecca: I THINK YOU NEED
TO MIX UP YOUR WARDROBE
A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN JUST
WHAT'S COMFORTABLE AND CASUAL.
I DON'T SEE,
LIKE, ONE DRESS
THAT YOU COULD WEAR
ON A CASTING.
Toccara: I AM
A FULL-FIGURED MODEL
AND JUST WANTED SOME
FEEDBACK ON THAT.
Paul: A LOT OF THE MORE
CLASSICAL HOUSES
ARE CUTTING PLUS SIZES.
YOU SHOULD HAVE A WONDERFUL
CAREER FOR YOURSELF, ABSOLUTELY.
Toccara: THANK YOU.
AND SHE WAS LIKE,
"YOU DON'T HAVE ANY DRESSES.
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY SKIRTS."
Yaya: LIKE, I KNOW
THERE HAS TO BE VERSATILITY.
- I KNOW THAT.
- Toccara: MM-HMM.
Yaya: BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
I'M GONNA WALK AROUND
LOOKING LIKE
SOMETHING THAT I'M NOT
OR THAT I'M NOT TRYING
TO REPRESENT.
Rebecca:
THEY'LL SEE THE BIG HAIR
AND THEY SEE THE AFRICAN PRINT
AND IT'S LIKE, "OH, MY GOD."
Yaya: I FELT LIKE
SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THAT I WOULDN'T FIT IN.
I WAS LIKE, "YEAH,
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT.
- I'M NOT TRYING TO FIT IN."
- Rebecca: OKAY, GALS.
I HAD SUCH A NICE TIME
GETTING TO KNOW YOU.
- Paul: MAKE MILLIONS, OKAY?
- Women: THANK YOU!
Yaya: I DON'T CARE.
Ann: TONIGHT WE'RE HEADING
TO UNCLE JACK'S STEAKHOUSE
FOR DINNER
WITH THE SEVEN OF US.
OKAY, IT'S, LIKE,
SETTING IN
THAT THERE'S REALLY
ONLY SEVEN OF US.
LIKE, I'M LOOKING AROUND LIKE,
"WHERE IS EVERYONE ELSE?"
AFTER LAST WEEK,
MY WHOLE, LIKE, OUTLOOK
ON THIS HAS CHANGED.
- Tyra: THAT'S NICE.
- Nigel: BEAUTIFUL.
Janice: BEST ONE YET.
Ann: AS LONG AS
I KEEP IMPROVING,
I THINK I HAVE A REALLY GOOD
CHANCE TO WIN THIS.
TO THE SEVEN.
Women: TO THE SEVEN.
Norelle: CLINK.
Women: (scream)
- Tyra: HI, EVERYBODY.
- Women: HEY! HI!
Tyra: GIVE ME HUGS,
EVERYBODY.
Eva: HEY, HOW YOU DOING?
Nicole: MISS TYRA POPS IN AND
SURPRISES EVERYBODY AT DINNER.
Tyra: SO WHAT'S GOING ON?
ACTUALLY, I WANNA
TASTE YOU GUYS' FOOD.
- IS THAT ALL RIGHT WITH YOU?
- Yaya: THIS SALAD--
Tyra: I'M NOTORIOUS
FOR THIS, YOU GUYS.
I, LIKE, EAT OFF
EVERYBODY'S PLATES.
Norelle: OKAY, WHAT DID WE
REALLY GET OURSELVES INTO?
LIKE, HOW MUCH IS THIS--
NOT LIKE,
IS THIS GONNA CHANGE
OUR LIVES AND AFFECT US,
LIKE, I'VE LEARNED
SO MUCH, AND I, LIKE,
FEEL SO BLESSED TO BE HERE
'CAUSE THERE'S
SO MANY THINGS ABOUT,
LIKE, THIS INDUSTRY
THAT I HAD NO IDEA.
Tyra: SEE, WHAT YOU GUYS
ARE SEEING ARE THE CRITICISM
THAT A MODEL GETS WHEN SHE
WALKS OUT THE DOOR.
THE ONLY THING IS
YOU GUYS ARE RIGHT THERE
- AND YOU HEAR IT.
- Eva: RIGHT.
Tyra: BUT AS DIFFICULT
AS IT IS, AND AS HARD AS IT IS
TO HEAR THAT CRITICISM
THAT'S SO HARSH--
Toccara: YOU LOOK LIKE A BOY.
YOU LOOK LIKE A LINEBACKER.
Tyra: BUT, UM,
IT'S A LUXURY,
AND YOU GUYS NEED
TO LOOK AT IT AS,
"WOW, I'M HEARING WHAT
PEOPLE SAY ABOUT ME."
IT REALLY DOES
CHANGE YOUR LIFE.
Toccara: SOMEONE SAID, UM,
AMERICA'S NOT READY FOR
A PLUS-SIZED TOP MODEL.
CAN YOU GIVE ME
A COMMENT?
Tyra: TO ME,
THE WHOLE PLUS-SIZED MARKET
KINDA REMINDS ME OF, LIKE,
BEING A BLACK MODEL
FORTY YEARS AGO.
YOU KNOW,
WHEN PEOPLE WERE LIKE,
"AMERICA'S JUST NOT READY
FOR A BLACK SUPERMODEL."
AND THEY PROBABLY
WERE SAYING THAT
BEFORE BEVERLY JOHNSON,
AND BEFORE IMAN.
THOSE ARE LIKE PIONEERS.
NAOMI SIMS
IS ANOTHER WOMAN.
SO YOU HAVE A LOT
WORKING AGAINST YOU.
I HAVE A LOT WORKING
AGAINST ME, TOO,
EVEN BEING A BLACK MODEL,
- EVEN IN THE NEW MILLENNIUM.
- Eva: RIGHT.
Tyra: SO I HAVE TO
WORK HARDER, STRIVE HARDER.
AND AS A PLUS-SIZED MODEL THAT'S
TRYING TO MAKE IT TO THE TOP,
YOU CAN'T BE AS GOOD
AS THE GIRLS AT THIS TABLE.
YOU HAVE TO BE BETTER THAN
TO GET THE SAME AMOUNT
OF RESPECT THAT THEY GET.
Toccara: I LISTEN
TO CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM,
BUT I NEVER LET IT
BREAK MY SPIRIT.
BUT I'M WORKING
AGAINST A LOT OF ODDS,
AND SO I HAVE TO BE
REALLY FOCUSED
AND I HAVE TO BE
ON TOP OF MY STUFF.
I HAVE TO BE A HUNDRED FEET
AHEAD OF THE REST.
Ann: TYRA MAIL!
Eva:
WHY IS EVERYBODY HERE?
Ann: NICOLE WANTS
TO READ IT.
- MAKE ONE UP. MAKE ONE UP.
- Nicole: OKAY.
Ann: (whispering)
SAY, "PACK YOUR BAGS.
YOU HAVE 20 MINUTES."
Eva: ANN, I AND NICOLE
PLAY A PRACTICAL JOKE ON
THE HOUSE WITH THE TYRA MAIL.
Nicole: "PACK YOUR BAGS.
YOU HAVE 20 MINUTES
TO BE IN EUROPE!"
Eva: OH, MY GOD!
OH, MY GOD!
Nicole:
WE HAVE 20 MINUTES!
Toccara: 20 MINUTES?
OH, MY! ARE YOU LYING?
Women: (shouting)
Nicole: NO, I--
Toccara: YOU LYING?
YOU'RE A...
Ann: WE'RE GOING TO EUROPE.
Toccara:
Y'ALL ARE-- THEY LYING.
- YEAH, THEY'RE LYING.
- Ann: (laughs)
Amanda: LIKE, "HA HA HA.
REAL FUNNY."
Eva: (laughs)
THE WHOLE HOUSE
WAS SO PISSED.
(laughs)
Yaya: LIKE, SERIOUSLY,
COMING TO THIS COMPETITION
I DID NOT REALIZE
THAT I WAS GONNA FEEL LIKE
I WAS IN JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL.
Ann: I'M GONNA THROW UP
FROM LAUGHING SO HARD.
Eva: NO ONE WANTS
TO HAVE FUN AROUND HERE.
OUR TYRA MAIL READS,
"GET READY FOR A 21st CENTURY
RED CARPET RIDE."
Ann: WE ENDED UP
GOING TO CENTURY 21,
- A DEPARTMENT STORE.
- Women: HEY.
Nicole: SO WE ARRIVE,
AND REBECCA WEINBERG
IS WAITING FOR US.
Rebecca: ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
WELCOME TO CENTURY 21.
THIS IS LIKE
THE BEST SHOPPING PLACE EVER.
Amanda: CENTURY 21
IS WHERE YOU CAN FIND
BIG DESIGNERS FOR
RIDICULOUSLY CHEAP.
Rebecca: HERE'S
THE CHALLENGE, RIGHT?
YOU GOTTA PUT TOGETHER
A HEAD-TO-TOE LOOK
FOR A DAYTIME EVENT.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE 15 MINUTES
TO PULL YOUR LOOKS TOGETHER.
THIS STORE
HAS GOT AMAZING STUFF.
Toccara: LIKE, "OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS SO GREAT."
THEY'VE GOT ALL THESE CLOTHES
AND ALL THESE DESIGNERS.
I'M LIKE, "WOW, I'M ABOUT
TO HAVE A FIELD DAY."
Rebecca: GO!
Ann: REBECCA SAYS THAT I NEED
TO, LIKE, HAVE DRESSY CLOTHES,
SO I'M JUST GONNA FOCUS
ON THAT.
Norelle: OH,
I LOOK LIKE A FREAK.
Yaya: I TOOK MY CONVERSATION
WITH REBECCA
AS JUST THAT--
A CONVERSATION.
NOT HOW I HAD TO PRESENT MYSELF
IN ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
I'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
WITHOUT COMPROMISING WHO I AM.
Toccara: IT TOOK ME FOREVER
TO FIND MY SIZE.
I DIDN'T WANT TO
BLOW OFF THE COMPETITION,
BUT IT WAS REALLY
A DOWNER.
Rebecca: I WAS A LITTLE
WORRIED ABOUT TOCCARA
BECAUSE HER PACE
WAS VERY SLOW,
WHEREAS
THE OTHER GIRLS WERE
FROM ONE END OF THE ROOM
TO THE OTHER.
THREE...
TWO...
TIME'S UP RIGHT NOW!
WHAT YOU HAVE
IS WHAT YOU'LL WEAR.
YOU'VE GOT A LIMO
COMING FOR YOU.
Women: (gasp)
Rebecca: LET'S GO, COME ON.
YOU HAVE VERY LITTLE TIME.
Nicole: WE HAVE TO GO HOME,
GET READY FOR OUR DAYTIME EVENT.
Toccara: I WAS, LIKE,
FRUSTRATED.
THE DRESSES--EITHER
THEY WERE BODY-FITTING
OR THEY WERE LIKE BIG CLOTH.
Eva: MM-HMM.
I KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN.
I DO FEEL SORRY FOR TOCCARA,
BUT BY THE SAME TOKEN,
YOU GOTTA STEP IT UP.
IT WAS FASHIONABLE.
IT'S FASHION.
IT LOOKS GOOD.
Toccara:
EVA IS VERY SWEET.
SHE'S TURNED OUT TO REALLY BE
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT ME.
Eva:
TOCCARA, TOCCARA.
Toccara: (laughs)
AND THAT WAS VERY HELPFUL.
Yaya: WE'RE NOT SURE
WHERE WE'RE GOING YET.
Eva: WE PULL UP IN A LIMO,
WALK IN.
Men: EVA! EVA! EVA!
Eva:
IT'S A RED CARPET EVENT.
ALL YOU HEAR IS,
"EVA! EVA! EVA!"
EVERYBODY'S SCREAMING YOUR NAME
AND TAKING PICTURES
AND WANTING YOU
TO LOOK HERE AND LOOK THERE,
AND A BIG SCREEN
WITH MY FACE UP THERE.
Sarah:
HI, EVA, "US WEEKLY."
- DO YOU HAVE A FEW MOMENTS?
- Eva: SURE.
Sarah: SO WHO ARE
YOU WEARING TODAY?
- YOU LOOK FANTASTIC.
- Eva: VALENTINO.
Sarah: WHO'S THE MOST
ANNOYING GIRL IN THE GROUP?
Eva: WHAT KIND OF FREAKIN'
QUESTIONS ARE THOSE?
PAUL AND HAMPTON
HAVE ALREADY PREPPED ME
ON HOW TO ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS.
Eva: EVERYONE'S
EQUALLY ANNOYING.
NEVER DISCLOSE A NAME.
YOU NEVER DO ANYTHING
TO PINPOINT ANYONE.
Sarah: THAT'S FANTASTIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Eva: THANK YOU.
Men:
EVA! EVA, OVER HERE!
YAYA! YAYA!
Yaya: I WAS NOT PREPARED
FOR WHAT WE WALKED INTO.
AND THERE WERE JUST
FLASHES, FLASHES, FLASHES,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"HA HA HA. WOW."
Sarah:
WHO ARE YOU WEARING?
Yaya: I'M WEARING
MOSTLY MOSCHINO TODAY.
Sarah: WHO'S THE PERSON
YOU HAVE THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
WITH IN THE HOUSE?
Yaya: I DON'T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH ANYONE.
Sarah: GREAT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Yaya: THANK YOU,
MY PLEASURE.
Man:
HERE. YAYA! YAYA!
NORELLE, LOOK HERE!
NORELLE!
- Sarah: SO YOU LOOK GREAT.
- Norelle: OH, THANK YOU.
Sarah: WHO ARE YOU WEARING?
Norelle: THIS IS
A MOSCHINO JACKET.
Sarah: NOW WHO WOULD SAY
ARE THE PEOPLE
YOU DON'T CLICK WITH
QUITE AS MUCH?
Norelle: UM...
HER NAME IS YAYA.
NOT THAT WE DON'T CLICK.
SHE'S JUST KIND OF STANDOFFISH.
Sarah: NORELLE GAVE A NAME
THAT COULD MAKE HER LOOK BAD.
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
- Norelle: OH, THANK YOU.
Men:
NORELLE! NORELLE!
AMANDA! AMANDA!
LOOK OVER HERE, AMANDA!
Sarah: ARE THERE MOMENTS
WHEN YOU WANT TO GIVE UP
OR SCREAM AT SOMEONE?
- Amanda: FOR SURE.
- Sarah: ANYONE IN PARTICULAR?
Amanda: THAT'S CONFIDENTIAL.
Sarah: GREAT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
- Amanda: THANK YOU.
- Men: AMANDA, OVER HERE!
OVER HERE, AMANDA.
ANN! ANN! OVER HERE!
Sarah:
WHO ARE YOU WEARING?
Ann: THE JACKET'S...
PURSE--VALENTINA.
Sarah: AND HAVE YOU SEEN
YOURSELF ON THE BIG SCREEN?
Ann: NO, I HAVE NOT.
THAT'S A FIRST.
Sarah: HAVE YOU HAD
ANY FIGHTS WITH ANYONE?
Ann: THERE HASN'T
REALLY BEEN ANYONE
THAT I'VE, YOU KNOW,
BUTTED HEADS WITH.
Men:
NICOLE! NICOLE!
OVER HERE! NICOLE!
Sarah: WHO'S CAUSING
THE MOST TENSION IN THE HOUSE?
Nicole: YOU CAN'T REALLY
PIN IT ON ONE SPECIFIC PERSON.
- Sarah: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
- Nicole: THANK YOU.
Men: NICOLE! NICOLE!
TOCCARA! TOCCARA!
Toccara: I'M WEARING
JOHN PAUL GAWTI-ERRE.
GAWTIE--
(laughs)
Sarah: SO TOCCARA--
SHE DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO PRONOUNCE
JEAN-PAUL GAULTIER,
AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
IT MAKES YOU LOOK
VERY SILLY.
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
- Toccara: THANK YOU.
Men: HERE! HERE!
Amanda: YEAH.
Eva: SHE WAS SAYING
LIKE, "WHO'S ANNOYING?"
AND I'M LIKE, "WHAT DO YOU
MEAN WHO'S ANNOYING?"
Yaya: SHE WAS FUNNY, THOUGH.
SHE WAS TRYING TO--
Eva: SHE WAS TRYING
TO READ YOU, BOY.
Norelle: I SAID
YOUR NAME IN MINE. HA!
Yaya: WHAT DID YOU SAY?
Norelle: I SAID,
"YAYA HAS A WALL BUILT UP
WHICH IS UNDERSTANDABLE."
Yaya: OH, A COMMENT. HA.
NORELLE GAVE A NAME,
WHICH WAS MINE,
AND I WASN'T
REALLY SURPRISED
BECAUSE I SEE HER
AS BEING VERY FLAKY.
I JUST NEVER MADE
A CONNECTION WITH HER.
Sarah: HELLO, EVERYONE.
WELL, IT'S BEEN REALLY
GREAT MEETING YOU
AND SEEING YOU AT WORK.
I'VE SEEN MANY RED CARPETS,
AND IT'S A SCARY PLACE.
WELL, EVA,
YOU DID VERY WELL.
YOU LOOKED GREAT.
YOU WALKED DOWN THE RUNWAY
REALLY NICELY.
NORELLE, YOU WERE
THE ONLY ONE TO NAME NAMES.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE SEEN
AS BITCHY.
AMANDA, YOU OBVIOUSLY LOVED
BEING ON THE RED CARPET.
YOU POSED VERY WELL.
YAYA, YOU, AGAIN,
ANOTHER PERSON
WHO REALLY ENJOYED
THE RED CARPET.
I DETECTED A DEFINITE
DIVA ATTITUDE THERE
WHICH SOMETIMES
COMES ACROSS BADLY.
Eva: YAYA--
SHE HAD DIVA SYNDROME
WHICH TRANSLATED
AS A BITCH.
Sarah: TOCCARA,
IF YOU'RE A MODEL,
AND YOU CAN'T PRONOUNCE
THE NAME
OF THE PERSON WHO'S
DESIGNED YOUR CLOTHES,
IT'S NOT GOOD.
NICOLE,
YOU'VE GOT A LOVELY SMILE.
YOU DIDN'T QUITE GIVE ACROSS
YOUR WHOLE PERSONALITY.
ANN, YOU LOOKED GREAT.
YOU MOVE VERY WELL,
POSED VERY WELL.
SO ON TO THE GOOD STUFF,
THE PERSON WHO
DID THE BEST TODAY...
IS YAYA.
Yaya: OOH!
Eva: SHE WINS?
YOU SEE THIS FACE?
THIS IS A CONFUSED FACE.
Ann: SO SHE'S WON
THREE IN A ROW.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
Yaya:
IT FEELS GOOD TO WIN.
I WANNA BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
Sarah: YOU'VE GOT
A SURPRISE WAITING FOR YOU
BACK AT THE HOUSE.
AND YOU JUST NEED NOW
TO CHOOSE ONE OTHER PERSON
TO ENJOY THAT SURPRISE
WITH YOU.
Yaya: NORELLE.
BECAUSE SHE THINKS--
I DON'T KNOW WHY SHE THINKS--
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I PICKED HER JUST
TO MAKE HER FEEL, YOU KNOW,
LIKE I'M MORE APPROACHABLE
OR WARMER.
Sarah:
SO THANKS VERY MUCH. BYE.
Women: IT WAS NICE
TO MEET YOU.
(knock on door)
- Man: HI.
- Eva: HI.
Man: I'M BRIAN.
THIS IS MARK.
- Eva: HI.
- Mark: HI THERE.
Eva: EVA. YAYA!
- Nicole: HI.
- Brian: HI, EVERYBODY.
- DO WE HAVE A WINNER IN HERE?
- Yaya: I AM.
Brian:
YOUR PRIZE TONIGHT
IS SOME PERSONAL CHEFING
- RIGHT FROM NU KITCHEN.
- Yaya: OOH!
Norelle: YAYA'S PRIZE
IS DINNER FROM NU KITCHEN.
THESE BOYS THAT, LIKE, COME
TO YOUR HOUSE AND COOK
THIS FABULOUS,
LIKE, HEALTHY DISH.
- YAY!
- Brian: ALL RIGHT, LADIES.
BON APPETIT!
Norelle: I SAID TODAY THAT--
THAT I FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE
A WALL BUILT UP,
BUT I UNDERSTAND
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM
JUST BECAUSE THIS IS
A COMPETITION
AND MAYBE THAT YOU DON'T WANNA
GET TOO CLOSE TO PEOPLE.
Yaya: MAYBE IT IS A WALL.
YOU KNOW, WITH NINE BLOCKS
THAT SPELL OUT "COMPETITION."
I'M LIKE, JUST
BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT WE'RE ALL REACHING
FOR THE SAME GOAL.
I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
TOLERANCE FOR FAKENESS.
YOU'RE THE ONE PERSON,
YOU KNOW, THAT I THINK IS--
I CAN USE THE WORD "GROWTH."
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE, I DON'T
HEAR YOU SPEAK THAT MUCH,
BUT WHEN I HEAR YOU SPEAK,
YOU SAY PROFOUND THINGS.
Norelle: WE UNDERSTOOD
WHERE WE'RE COMING FROM,
WHICH I'M SO GLAD
THAT WE GOT TO DO,
JUST BECAUSE I HAD
NOTHING OF YAYA,
AND NOW I HAVE
A LITTLE SOMETHING.
- THANK YOU.
- Yaya: OH.
Ann: (gasps)
"TOMORROW YOU WILL BE DRAPED
IN THE FINEST SILK IN THE WORLD.
BE READY TO LEAVE AT 8
IN THE MORNING."
- Jay: HELLO.
- Women: HELLO.
Jay: SO THE COMPETITION
IS GETTING TOUGH.
TODAY WE ARE GOING RIGHT
BACK IN TO BEAUTY SHOTS.
BUT WE WANNA DO
SOMETHING ELSE,
SO WE HAVE DIAMONDS TODAY.
Women: YAY!
Jay: YES, TODAY WE HAVE THE
VERRAGIO PLATINUM COLLECTION.
SO I JUST WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
HIS NAME IS BILL DIODATO.
COME OUT HERE, BILL.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK?
THEY'RE A PRETTY BUNCH.
Bill: GORGEOUS.
Jay: OKAY, COOL.
WE'LL START.
Toccara: I'M READY TO GO.
I'M READY TO WORK THIS.
THIS IS GONNA BE ABSOLUTELY
FABULOUS. F-A-B-O--
Jay: IF I WERE YOU,
I'D BE IN THE MIRROR
PRACTICING YOUR FACE
RIGHT NOW.
Ann: I'M WAITING FOR MY HAIR.
Jay: I WOULDN'T WORRY
ABOUT HAIR.
I'D WORRY ABOUT GIVING
A BEAUTIFUL FACE. TRUST ME.
Eva: I'M SO EXCITED.
IT'S ACTUALLY EASIER
TO DO A BEAUTY SHOT, TO ME,
BECAUSE IT'S LIKE, "HEY,
LOOK AT ME. IT'S MY FACE."
IT'S SO EASY, YOU KNOW?
Jay: SEE,
THAT'S REALLY PRETTY.
OKAY, LET'S TAKE YOU
ON SET.
HEY, GUYS, I NEED TO TALK
TO ALL OF YOU AT ONCE.
SO TO MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE A TYPICAL JEWELRY AD,
WE DO HAVE SOMEONE ELSE FOR YOU
TO POSE WITH TODAY
IN YOUR SHOT.
SO CAN WE HAVE
OUR OTHER PERSON?
Ann: YEAH!
Eva: ARE WE POSING
WITH HER OR THE SPIDER?
- Jay: THE TARANTULA.
- Ann: YES!
Jay: THE TARANTULA'S
VERY SAFE,
BUT WE DO HAVE
E.M.S. ON THE SIDE--
Eva: WHAT DO YOU MEAN,
"IT'S VERY SAFE"?
WHY WOULD YOU HAVE TO
HAVE E.M.S. IF IT'S SAFE?
Jay: WE HAVE E.M.S. HERE
ALL THE TIME.
Eva: I DON'T LIKE SPIDERS.
I DON'T WANT THEM
TO TOUCH ME.
I DON'T WANT
TO BE NEAR THEM.
IT'S A HORRIBLE PHOBIA
I'VE ALWAYS HAD.
I'M REALLY IFFY RIGHT NOW.
Jay: YOU READY, NICOLE?
- Nicole: HE'S TICKLING ME.
- Bill: THAT'S GOOD.
Eva: WHEN JAY SAID THERE WAS
GONNA BE A TARANTULA,
I WAS SCARED.
IT'S PETRIFYING. IT'S SO SCARY.
Ann: AAH!
Jay: NO, NO, YOU GOTTA GO.
Nicole: REALLY BADASS MISS EVA
COULDN'T HANDLE IT.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK
SHE'S THE TOUGHEST
AND BADDEST OF US ALL.
SHE'S JUST THE LOUDEST.
Bill: RELAX.
KEEP YOUR EYES AT ME.
I KNOW IT'S HARD RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S PERFECT.
FLAWLESS.
DON'T MOVE.
FANTASTIC.
Jay: NICOLE WAS REALLY
A PLEASURE TO SHOOT TODAY.
50% OF HER FRAMES
WERE AMAZING,
AND FOR ANY TOP MODEL,
THAT'S A FEAT.
- Bill: GOT IT.
- Jay: OKAY, YEAH, WE GOT IT.
Bill: FANTASTIC.
Norelle: (inhales sharply)
Yaya: (inhales sharply)
- Ann: IT'S NOT GONNA HURT.
- Toccara: OOH, IT MIGHT. OOH.
Ann: A STUPID SPIDER
IS NOT GONNA STOP ME
FROM, LIKE,
PURSUING MY DREAM.
Eva: CAN WE TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE?
Ann: EVA IS,
LIKE, FLIPPING OUT
LIKE A CHILD WOULD
THROW A FIT.
HELLO, McFLY!
LIKE, STAY FOCUSED.
♪ COME ON, FLASHIN' ♪
♪ LACED WITH SHINY THINGS ♪
♪ FLASHIN' ♪
♪ GOLD AND DIAMOND RINGS ♪
- ♪ FLASHIN'... ♪
- Bill: GORGEOUS.
NICE WORK.
THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
Jay: YOU DEFINITELY HAVE
SOME REALLY GREAT OPTIONS.
Bill: RELAX THAT HAND.
RELAX THAT HAND.
Yaya: DO I LOOK STIFF?
Jay: I WANNA JUST TRY
SOMETHING THAT BRINGS
A LITTLE MORE LIFE,
A LITTLE MORE MOVEMENT.
♪ FLASHIN' ♪
♪ LACED WITH SHINY THINGS ♪
♪ GOLD AND DIAMOND RINGS ♪♪
- Bill: FANTASTIC. DONE.
- Jay: WE GOT IT.
I LIKED THIS--
WHERE WE WERE GOING WITH THIS.
OH, I LOVE THAT SHOT.
Amanda: (squeals)
SPIDERS, SPIDERS.
GET IT OFF.
CAN I OPEN MY EYE
WITHOUT THE SPIDER CLAW
GOING IN MY CORNEA?
Jay: AMANDA,
IF YOU HOLD STILL,
THE SPIDER WON'T PUT ITS FINGER
IN YOUR EYES,
BUT YOU HAVE
TO OPEN THEM UP.
Bill: I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO TELL YOU, JAY.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S WORKING.
Jay: A LITTLE LESS
FRIENDLY, AMANDA.
IT'S GETTING A LITTLE
COMMERCIAL-LOOKIN'.
CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
YOU KNOW,
AMANDA STRUGGLED TODAY.
UP THAT CLOSE, I DON'T KNOW
IF AMANDA IS A BEAUTY GIRL.
Bill: I'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR THAT, YEAH.
Jay: THANK YOU, AMANDA.
Amanda:
OKAY, IT'S TANGLED.
Jay: EVA'S ALREADY CRYING.
YOU ALL RIGHT?
Danilo: I THINK WE'LL ONLY
HAVE ONE SPIDER FATALITY TODAY.
Jay: LET'S JUST HOPE
THE SPIDER DOESN'T THINK
THE LASH IS HIS PARTNER.
Danilo: SHE HAS
A LOOK ON HER FACE
I'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE TODAY--
PANIC-STRICKEN.
- Eva: I'M SO SORRY, A.J.
- A.J.: THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
Amanda: TO SEE HER CRYING
OVER SOMETHING LIKE A SPIDER
MAKES DIVA EVA SEEM HUMAN.
Bill: A LITTLE MORE ENERGY,
HON, LITTLE MORE ENERGY.
Jay: SHE JUST DOES NOT
FEEL COMFORTABLE AT ALL.
Bill:
I'M NOT SEEING ANYTHING.
MORE. TURN TO ME. MORE.
IF YOU WANNA BE AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL, YOU GOTTA FOCUS.
Jay: NORELLE IS JUST NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH BEAUTY.
SHE ONLY FEELS COMFORTABLE
WITH A FACE FULL OF MAKEUP
AND A CAMERA PULLED OFF
FROM HER.
Bill: DONE.
MORE. GOOD. MORE, MORE.
THIS WAY.
Toccara: IT'S
THE ITSY-BITSY SPIDER.
Bill: WIDE EYES.
BIGGER EYES, BIGGER EYES.
YOU DON'T WANT 'EM
TOO BIG. GREAT.
OKAY, OPEN YOUR EYES.
RIGHT HERE AT ME.
Bill: AND TOCCARA
HAD GREAT ENERGY,
A DEFINITE SWEETHEART,
NOT A GREAT BEAUTY GIRL.
THAT'S IT, LOVE.
YOU'RE DONE.
THAT'S THE MOST FIERCE
THAT SHE'S LOOKED.
- Jay: YOU LIKE THAT ONE?
- Yaya: LOOK AT THEIR FACES.
GO READ. GO READ THEM.
Jay: THAT'S IT.
Bill: I MEAN,
I DID THE BEST I COULD.
GREAT.
NOT TOO WIDE-EYED.
A LITTLE MORE ALIVE.
FOCUS, FOCUS. GREAT.
LET'S BRING THAT SPIDER
DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
BEHIND THE EYES.
DON'T FORCE IT.
Jay: ANN, HELP ME
HELP YOU OVERCOME THIS.
LIKE, 'CAUSE I'M TOTALLY
AT A LOSS.
THINK OF SOMETHING OTHER THAN
SITTING IN FRONT OF THAT CAMERA.
Bill:
REAL ALIVE. GORGEOUS.
Jay:
BILL, LOOK AT THIS.
Bill: VERY GOOD.
WHEN YOU GET THERE,
STAY THERE.
- Jay: IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
- Bill: GORGEOUS EYES.
FANTASTIC.
AND WE SHOT 125 FRAMES,
AND YOU DON'T WANNA HAVE
TO SHOOT THAT MANY FRAMES
TO GET THE SHOT.
Jay: YEAH, WE'RE GOOD.
SHE'S CONSISTENTLY FLAT
ON FILM.
Bill: HOW ARE YOU, EVA,
WITH THE TARANTULA?
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT IT?
Eva: LET'S JUST GET
THE FILM DONE.
I'M DEATHLY AFRAID.
Bill: SHE'S VERY, VERY
NERVOUS ABOUT THIS.
Bill: CAN WE MOVE
THE SPIDER ONTO HER HAND?
RELAX YOUR HAND
FOR A SECOND, LOVE.
RELAX.
LET'S GET SOME BLOOD
BACK IN THERE.
Ann:
(whispers) SHE'S CRYING.
Amanda: REALLY?
Bill: CAN WE GET A TISSUE
FOR HER, PLEASE?
Eva: SPIDER COMES OFF.
I JUST START CRYING.
AND I WAS NOT FINISHED
WITH THE SHOOT.
I WASN'T EVEN
HALFWAY DONE YET.
Jay:
TEARS? LET ME FIX IT.
LET ME FIX, LET ME FIX.
CAN WE MOVE THE LIGHT
SO I CAN SEE HER FACE?
Eva: I'M SO SORRY.
Bill: PROBABLY ABOUT
FIVE MORE MINUTES,
AND WE'LL BE DONE.
Jay: YOU'RE COOL.
ARE YOU READY TO SHOOT
A LITTLE MORE?
YOU JUST KEEP THOSE THERE.
- READY?
- Eva: MM-HMM. LET'S GO.
Bill: STAY WITH ME
THE WHOLE TIME, OKAY?
NO WORRIES ABOUT IT, OKAY?
GORGEOUS.
GETTIN' THIS. GORGEOUS.
CAN YOU MOVE
THE SPIDER, PLEASE?
Man: THIS IS WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE A PRO, HON.
Bill: FANTASTIC.
- Jay: HEY, BILL?
- Bill: YEAH.
Jay: MIGHT AS WELL
TAKE HER OUT OF THAT TORTURE.
Bill: SHE'S HAVING
A TOUGH TIME.
Jay: SHE COULD GET
CUT 'CAUSE OF THIS.
Yaya: COME WITH ME.
Eva: I'M PROUD OF MYSELF
AT THE FACT
THAT I GOT THROUGH IT.
I'M DISAPPOINTED THAT
I SHOWED THE VULNERABILITY.
Eva's mom:
How you doing?
Eva:
OH, MOTHER, I HAD A DAY.
I HAD TO DO A CHALLENGE
WITH A TARANTULA.
- Eva's mom: (gasps)
- Eva: MOM, IT WAS HORRIBLE.
Eva's mom: Oh, sweetie.
Eva: I KNOW, AND I JUST--
I DON'T WANNA GET SENT HOME
BECAUSE OF IT, YOU KNOW?
Ann: HONESTLY, FOR AS HARD-ASS
AS EVA COMES OFF TO BE,
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED
THAT SHE WAS CRYING
SO MUCH ABOUT THE SPIDER.
Eva: GETTING DOWN TO IT,
AND ANY MISTAKE YOU MAKE,
YOU KNOW, COULD--
IT COULD BE THE END OF IT,
AND I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S JUST SO FRUSTRATING.
Nicole:
EVA'S REALLY STRESSING.
SHE'S WORRIED THAT HER
INABILITY TO PERFORM
WITH A SPIDER ON HER FACE
IS GONNA SEND HER HOME,
SO I DON'T THINK THAT
SHE REALLY IS CUT OUT
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
Eva: I ALLOWED IT
TO GET TO ME, YOU KNOW?
'CAUSE I DON'T LET
NOTHING GET TO ME.
I JUST FEEL LIKE
I LET MYSELF SLIP, YOU KNOW?
I'M ACTUALLY VULNERABLE
AT THIS POINT.
I MAY BE GOING HOME.
Amanda: IT'S TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU MEET
WITH THE JUDGES."
Eva: SOMEONE'S GOING HOME,
GUYS.
Toccara: I THINK EVERYBODY IS
A LITTLE IFFY ABOUT TOMORROW,
SO...
I WAS REALLY A LITTLE DOWN,
YOU KNOW, DURING THE WEEK,
BUT I'M STILL GONNA BE ME,
AND I'M STILL GONNA BE FABULOUS.
I'M STILL GONNA GIVE
ALL THAT I HAVE.
Eva: I HOPE
JAY'S NOT MAD AT ME.
I WAS SUCH A PUNK.
I FEEL LIKE...
I DON'T KNOW HOW MY PICTURES
ARE GONNA TURN OUT.
I'M SO SORRY.
I DON'T KNOW IF MY FEAR'S
GONNA PROJECT,
AND IT'S JUST SO UPSETTING.
I JUST DON'T FEEL GOOD.
Ann: LIKE, IT WAS SO STRANGE
'CAUSE HE CALLED ME OVER THERE.
Jay: I'D WORRY ABOUT GIVING
A BEAUTIFUL FACE, TRUST ME.
Ann: I THOUGHT HE WAS
GONNA CALL ME UGLY
OR STUPID OR SOMETHING.
I'M GOING TO BE
NERVOUS TONIGHT AT PANEL,
JUST BECAUSE
IF I HAVE A BAD PICTURE,
I FEEL LIKE I WILL BE
THE ONE GOING HOME.
Tyra: HEY, GIRLS.
Women: HELLO.
Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR EIGHTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER
TO FINDING OUT WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WE HAVE SOME AMAZING PRIZES--
A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH THE TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING AGENCY, FORD MODELS,
A PHOTO SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
SHOT BY WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR ME
TO INTRODUCE
OUR PANEL OF JUDGES--
JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODEL EVER
- TO EXIST ON THIS PLANET.
- Janice: FIRST.
Tyra: NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLE MARIN, A PROMINENT FASHION
EDITOR AND STYLIST.
WE HAVE OUR SPECIAL
GUEST JUDGE, REBECCA WEINBERG...
Rebecca: GOOD TO SEE
YOU ALL AGAIN.
Tyra: WHO IS A CELEBRITY
STYLIST EXTRAORDINAIRE.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR YOUR
INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND REBECCA IS GOING TO
ADMINISTER YOUR TEST.
Rebecca: OKAY, GIRLS, HERE ARE
FIVE DIFFERENT OPTIONS OF HATS.
(laughter)
Rebecca: YOU'RE GOING
TO PICK ONE OF THESE HATS.
EACH ONE OF THEM REPRESENTING
A DIFFERENT STYLE.
CHOOSE ONE, AND
YOU'LL HAVE TEN MINUTES
TO BUILD YOUR IMAGE AROUND
YOUR HAT OF CHOICE.
GO.
♪ COME ON ♪♪
♪♪♪
Tyra:
FIRST, WE HAVE NICOLE.
Janice: WHOO-HOO!
Tyra: SO YOU CHOSE
THE MOTORCYCLE HAT
AND THEN THREW ON
A TIARA, TOO.
Nigel: YOU CAME OUT LIKE THIS,
I WAS LIKE, "WHOA. OKAY."
Janice: YOU GOT SCARED.
Nigel: I DID KINDA
GET SCARED.
IT SEEMED ALMOST LIKE YOU WERE
PUTTING ON A BIT OF AN ACT.
Rebecca: TOO FANTASY.
IT'S NOT FASHION.
Tyra:
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
IT WAS FOR DIAMONDS,
AND YOU WERE ACCESSORIZED
WITH A LIVE TARANTULA.
Janice: UGH.
Tyra: HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
- Janice: THAT'S A LIVE BUG.
- Nigel: WOW.
Nolé: THIS PHOTOGRAPH
DOESN'T LOOK ANYTHING LIKE YOU.
YOU REALLY TRANSFORMED.
Nigel: NO DOUBT
YOU'VE GOT THE POWER
TO BE A GOOD BEAUTY MODEL.
Janice: LOOKS MORE LIKE
AN ALBUM COVER.
Tyra: YOU'RE RIGHT.
I SEE A RECORDING ARTIST,
LIKE YOU SHOULD SING...
(dramatic voice) LIKE THIS. AHH.
Janice: (laughs)
Tyra: TOCCARA.
Nigel: TOCCARA,
I DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
OTHER THAN STICK A HAT
ON YOUR HEAD.
Janice: SEE, YOU COULD
HAVE COME OUT AS TOCCARA,
LIKE, "YEE-HAW, HONEY!"
YOU KNOW, AND SHOWN US
THAT TOCCARA PERSONALITY.
- ARE YOU WITH ME ON THIS?
- Toccara: I HEAR YOU.
Janice: YOU HEAR ME,
BUT DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
Toccara: I AGREE. I'M JUST
SOAKING IT IN.
- I'LL TAKE IT.
- Janice: SHE'S TAKING IT.
Tyra:
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: THE TARANTULA'S
TAKING OVER
THE FACE AND THE JEWELRY.
IT'S LIKE A BIG HAIRY MOLE--
A TARANTULA MOLE.
Nolé: IT'S A GREAT SHOT
FOR THE SPIDER.
Janice: YEAH.
HOW'D YOU FEEL
WITH A LIVE TARANTULA
WALKING ALL OVER YOUR
GORGEOUS FACE?
Toccara: IT WAS
A GREAT EXPERIENCE.
- Janice: THAT'S IT?
- Tyra: WHERE ARE YOU?
- Toccara: NO, I MEAN--
- Janice: PULL IT OUT!
- WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED?
- Tyra: YOU'RE NOT HERE.
Toccara: I AM HERE!
I HAD A GOOD TIME.
- Tyra: SOMETHING'S WEIRD.
- Janice: YEAH.
Tyra: YOU'VE CHECKED OUT.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE I TOLD YOU
YOU'RE VIVACIOUS,
YOU'RE GREAT?
I WANNA SEE THAT,
AND WHEN YOU COME IN HERE,
AND YOU'RE LIKE,
"THE PICTURE'S NICE.
THE EXPERIENCE
WAS LOVELY."
Nigel: YOU NEED TO INSTALL
THE PERSONALITY CHIP
BACK INTO YOU.
Toccara: OKAY.
Tyra: NEXT WE HAVE AMANDA.
Nolé: THIS IS
A DROP-DEAD LOOK.
Nigel:
VERY ANNIE LENNOX.
THAT'S REALLY
A GOOD LOOK FOR YOU.
Tyra: I THINK FROM HEAD TO TOE,
YOU'RE PERFECTION.
I LIKE THE CONTRAST.
I LIKE THE TORN JEANS
WITH THE SHIRT.
LIKE, I'M FEELING
LIKE A STAR.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Rebecca: NOT YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nigel: THIS IS A VERY
OLD-FASHIONED-LOOKING
PICTURE, TOO.
Nolé: THAT'S WHAT
I WAS GONNA SAY.
IT HAS AN OLD GLAMOUR,
BUT WHAT'S WRONG IS THAT
YOU LOOK VERY STIFF.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE FAKELY
PEEKING THROUGH YOUR FINGERS.
- Tyra: ANN.
- Janice: YEE-HAW, ANNIE.
Tyra: WHAT IMAGE ARE YOU
TRYING TO PORTRAY?
Ann: JUST MY OWN PERSONAL
IMAGE, I GUESS. IT'S JUST ME.
Nigel: FOR ME,
THIS WHOLE THING IS ACTUALLY
SOMEWHAT OF A DISASTER,
FROM TOP TO BOTTOM.
IS YOUR T-SHIRT DIRTY?
- Janice: (gasps)
- Ann: UM...
Rebecca: YOUR LACK
OF INTEREST WITH CLOTHING--
IT'S SO APPARENT.
THE SKIRT IS HIDEOUS.
YOU SHOULD REALLY
THROW IT OUT.
AND THE UGG BOOT--
YOU COULD TAKE THOSE
AND PUT THAT WITH THE SKIRT.
Janice: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH,
THEY'RE OVER.
Rebecca: YOU DON'T
REALLY GIVE A DAMN,
AND IT SHOWS.
Tyra:
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: YOU HAVE
A BEAUTIFUL-SHAPED FACE,
BUT FOR SOME REASON, I'M JUST
NOT DRAWN TO IT.
Nigel: I THINK
YOU'RE GORGEOUS,
BUT IT'S MORE THAN
BEING GORGEOUS.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT MODELING,
AND THIS ISN'T SO MUCH MODELING.
THIS IS JUST BEING THERE
AND BEING GORGEOUS.
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID
THAT YOUR EYES WERE DEAD
AND THAT
YOU ONLY HAD ONE SHOT.
Janice: ONLY ONE SHOT?
Nolé: THAT IS
SO NOT GOOD, ANN.
Tyra: NORELLE.
Norelle: I THINK
THIS IS A CLASSIC HAT,
BUT I FEEL LIKE I'M
A CLASSIC BEAUTY.
Nigel: NORELLE,
I THINK THIS IS ACTUALLY
THE PRETTIEST I'VE SEEN YOU.
- Norelle: THANK YOU.
- Nigel: YOU REALLY LOOK LOVELY.
Nolé: YOU NEED TO LEARN
HOW TO WEAR THE CLOTHES.
YOU NEED TO COME THROUGH.
Rebecca: RED LIP
AND SOME ATTITUDE, I THINK,
COULD HAVE TAKEN IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
Tyra:
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nigel: GOT SOME POWER
IN YOUR EYES.
BE NICE TO SEE YOUR LIPS
A LITTLE BIT MORE RELAXED.
Tyra: YOUR MOUTH IS JUST
REALLY, REALLY TENSE,
AND SOMETIMES IT'S
ABOUT PARTING IT A LITTLE,
JUST OPEN A LITTLE BIT
TO TAKE THAT AWAY.
ALL RIGHT, EVA, SO WHY DID YOU
CHOOSE THE MOTORCYCLE HAT?
Eva: BECAUSE I LOVE LEATHER,
AND IT'S A LITTLE MORE EDGY,
A LITTLE MORE RISQUE.
Nigel: THAT DOES NOT LOOK
LIKE A MODEL AT ALL.
IT LOOKS TOO CHEAP.
Rebecca:
COMBINING THAT CUTE TOP
WITH THAT SORT OF TRASHY
TYPE OF SKIRT--
IT DOESN'T LOOK CHIC.
IT KIND OF LOOKS LIKE
A GO-GO DANCER
ON THE WAY HOME
FROM A NIGHT OUT.
Tyra:
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
- WOW.
- Janice: WORK IT!
Nolé: IF I WAS LOOKING
AT THIS IN A MAGAZINE,
I THINK YOU'VE TOTALLY
NAILED IT
BECAUSE I'D WANNA KNOW
WHO THOSE RINGS WERE FROM.
Janice:
I'M GIVING THIS A 10.
Tyra: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT IT?
I SAW YOU
TAKE YOUR BREATH AWAY.
Eva: I AM AMAZED. I WAS
PETRIFIED OF THE SPIDER.
Janice: TRY POSING
ON A LIVE CROCODILE, HONEY.
Nigel: YOU KNOW, WELL DONE.
IT'S ABOUT GETTING THE SHOT.
- Eva: THANK YOU.
- Tyra: YAYA.
Yaya: EXCUSE ME.
Tyra: WHY DID YOU CHOOSE
THE COWBOY HAT?
Yaya: IT'S MORE
ON THE SIMPLE SIDE
COMPARED TO THE OTHER HATS
SO THAT I CAN GO CRAZY
WITH ACCESSORIES
AND EXPRESS MYSELF
WITHOUT BEING CLICHE.
Nigel: YAYA, I THINK
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
I THINK EVERYONE
PROBABLY PEGGED YOU
AS GOING FOR THE TYPICAL
AFRICAN HAT.
Nolé: YAYA, I FEEL
HALF AFRICAN, HALF COWGIRL.
LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE ABOUT
TO RIDE A GIRAFFE.
I THINK--
I'M NOT FEELING IT.
Rebecca: YOU HAVE
THIS INTENSITY TO PROVE
YOUR SORT OF AFRICAN-NESS,
AND I THINK THAT SOMETIMES
IT'S OVERBEARING.
IT'S JUST TOO MUCH.
IT'S SORT OF A LAYER
ON TOP OF A LAYER.
Yaya: IN RESPONSE TO TRYING
TO PROVE MYSELF AS AN AFRICAN,
THAT'S JUST
WHERE I COME FROM.
IT'S VERY NATURAL TO ME,
AND I DID NOT CHOOSE
THAT HAT
FOR THE VERY SPECIFIC REASON
THAT IT'S VERY CLICHE.
THE FABRIC
THAT IT'S MADE FROM
IS VERY ARTIFICIAL,
VERY CHEAP, FAKE KENTE.
- Nigel: YAYA...
- Yaya: I DIDN'T HAVE THE TIME--
I KNOW I'M RUNNING ON.
Tyra: THERE'S A DIFFERENT WAY
OF EXPLAINING YOURSELF
AND BEING DEFENSIVE, AND
YOU'RE BEING VERY DEFENSIVE,
AND IT'S NOT ATTRACTIVE.
Yaya: JUST BECAUSE WE HAD
A TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
"AFROCENTRICITY" BEFORE,
AND IT'S KIND OF...
MISUNDERSTOOD.
Tyra: I'M ALL ABOUT, LIKE,
EXPRESSING YOURSELF
IN YOUR CULTURE, BUT IT'S
STILL DONE IN A FASHION WAY.
YOU WANT YOUR OUTFIT TO BE
"LOOK AT ME!"
AND THIS OUTFIT IS
"LOOK OVER THERE."
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
SEE, THAT'S A STAR, YAYA.
- THEY WANNA LOOK AT... THAT.
- Janice: GORGEOUS!
Nigel: THAT'S
THE BEST PICTURE OF ALL.
Janice: THAT'S
SELLING JEWELRY.
Tyra: YOU SEE HOW
INSPIRED THE PANEL IS
- BY LOOKING AT THAT?
- Nigel: ABSOLUTELY.
Tyra: IT'S BECAUSE
IT'S ASPIRATIONAL,
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO LOOK LIKE THAT.
NOT EVERY GIRL ON
THE STREET CAN LOOK LIKE THAT.
BUT EVERY GIRL ON THE STREET
CAN LOOK LIKE THIS.
- Nolé: MM-HMM.
- Janice: THERE YOU GO.
MODEL, MODEL, MODEL.
Tyra: TOCCARA.
Nigel: TOCCARA
HAS BECOME A SHELL.
SHE'S BECOME A GHOST OF
HER ORIGINAL SELF.
WHEN WE FIRST MET HER,
SHE HAD THIS MASSIVE
BUBBLY PERSONALITY WHICH
WENT ALONG WITH HER PHYSIQUE
AND EVERYTHING ELSE ABOUT HER,
AND NOW SHE JUST CHECKED OUT.
Nolé: TOCCARA IS
AN INCREDIBLY BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
SHE HAS A GREAT FACE,
AND WHEN YOU SHOOT HER,
IT'S FLAWLESS.
Tyra: TOCCARA HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO BE A STAR.
FOR SOME REASON, TODAY SHE
WALKED IN HERE AND GAVE UP.
- NORELLE.
- Nolé: IN THIS IMAGE,
I THINK THAT SHE WAS
REALLY TRYING.
I THINK SHE STILL
HASN'T MASTERED IT, THOUGH.
Tyra: IN PICTURES, I THINK SHE
DOES HAVE SOMETHING SPECIAL.
SHE'S PHOTOGENIC.
THE CAMERA LIKES HER FACE.
EVA.
Nolé: EVA SLAM-DUNKED
THIS SHOOT.
IT'S AN AMAZING IMAGE.
Janice: SHE'S FLAWLESS
EXCEPT FOR HER HANDS,
WHICH REALLY LOOK
LIKE BASEBALL MITTS.
Tyra: YAYA.
Janice: THIS GIRL
IS AN AD CAMPAIGN WINNER.
Nolé: AND IN THIS PHOTO,
IT'S KIND OF LIKE
A CHOCOLATE "BARBARELLA"
WITH THE HAIR.
Tyra: YAYA TAKES A BEAUTIFUL
PICTURE EFFORTLESSLY.
SHE'S BRINGING
SOMETHING FROM INSIDE.
BUT THE OTHER THING THAT
YAYA BRINGS FROM INSIDE
THAT IS SO UGLY
IS THAT SUPERIORITY,
CONDESCENDING ATTITUDE.
- Janice: OOPS.
- Tyra: NICOLE.
Janice: IS SUPPOSED TO BE
SELLING BEAUTIFUL JEWELRY,
AND SHE DIDN'T PULL IT OFF
IN THIS PICTURE.
Tyra: NICOLE DOES TAKE
REALLY BEAUTIFUL PICTURES,
BUT A LOT OF THE TIMES TO ME,
IT'S JUST A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
I'M NOT SURE SHE HAS ANYTHING
THAT REALLY CAN READ AS A STAR
IN TERMS OF PERSONALITY.
ANN.
Nigel: ANN SEEMS TO BE
ALMOST INCAPABLE
OF TAKING
A GOOD PICTURE.
Rebecca: SHE'S NOT INTERESTED
IN HER SELF-IMAGE.
SHE DOESN'T GIVE A DAMN,
AND IT SHOWED TONIGHT.
Nolé: I THINK ANN'S RUN
IS OVER FOR ME.
- SHE'S OUT.
- Tyra: AMANDA.
Janice: AMANDA IS DEAD
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
THERE'S NOTHING
COMING THROUGH THE EYES.
Tyra: I THINK AMANDA'S
RESTING ON PRETTY.
SHE NEEDS TO STEP UP HER GAME,
OR ELSE SHE'LL GO BYE-BYE.
Janice: BYE-BYE.
Tyra: THERE ARE SEVEN
BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SIX PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE SIX OF YOU
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
NICOLE.
Nicole: WOW.
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Nicole: THANK YOU.
Tyra: EVA.
I WANNA COMMEND YOU
ON THIS PHOTO
BECAUSE YOU SAID
THAT YOU WERE CRYING.
I CANNOT SEE THIS
ON THAT PICTURE.
- GOOD JOB.
- Eva: THANK YOU.
Tyra: AMANDA.
AMANDA, THIS LOOK
IS RED CARPET STAR,
BUT THIS PICTURE
IS LUKEWARM.
YAYA.
YAYA, THIS PICTURE
IS STUNNING.
I MEAN, THIS IS AMAZING.
BUT WHAT'S NOT AMAZING
IS YOUR APPEARANCE.
THINK A LITTLE BIT MORE GLAMOUR
AS OPPOSED TO NATURAL,
'CAUSE THIS IS GLAMOROUS,
AND THIS IS AMAZING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
Yaya: THANK YOU,
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY
I'M SORRY FOR BEING DEFENSIVE
WHEN YOU GAVE ME--
I TOTALLY TOOK IN
EVERYTHING YOU SAID.
AND I REALLY MEAN IT.
I WAS SO OUTSIDE
OF MYSELF.
Tyra: WELL,
THAT WAS THE OTHER CRITIQUE
THAT I WAS GONNA GIVE YOU
THAT I FORGOT,
SO COME RIGHT BACK.
YOU NEED TO APOLOGIZE
TO THE FAKE KENTE CLOTH
AFRICAN HAT.
YAYA, IT WAS LIKE
YOU WERE ON THIS PEDESTAL,
AND THIS HAT SMELLED
LIKE DOOKIE.
YOU'RE INSULTING THE PERSON
THAT CHOSE THAT HAT.
ALL YOU HAD TO DO WAS SAY,
"NO, THAT WASN'T MY STYLE.
IT WAS A LITTLE OBVIOUS."
IT WAS VERY INSULTING,
AND IN THIS INDUSTRY,
THERE'S GONNA BE PEOPLE
THAT REALLY ARE SENSITIVE,
AND WORD WILL SPREAD, AND NO ONE
WILL EVER WANNA WORK WITH YOU.
Yaya: I UNDERSTAND THAT,
AND I APOLOGIZE.
Tyra: NORELLE.
FOR SOMEONE THAT IS LOOKING
SO SURPRISED AND SHOCKED,
YOU SURE DID HAVE
A NICE SMILE ON YOUR FACE.
Norelle: I'M JUST BLESSED
TO BE HERE AND--
Tyra: BLESSED TO BE HERE AND
THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING HOME,
SO YOU'RE GONNA PUT A SMILE
ON YOUR FACE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Norelle:
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Tyra: WILL TOCCARA AND ANN
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS ONE PHOTO
REPRESENTS THE GIRL
THAT WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE APARTMENT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND LEAVE.
THE MODELING INDUSTRY
IS NOT JUST ABOUT BEAUTY.
IT'S ABOUT DRIVE.
TOCCARA, I KNEW FROM DAY ONE
THAT YOU WANTED THIS,
THAT THIS WAS SOMETHING
THAT YOU LIVED AND BREATHED
AND WAS F-A-B-O,
"I AM FABULOUS AND
I WANT THIS SO BAD."
ANN, I SAW A COMPETITOR
IN YOU.
I SAW SOMEONE
THAT WANTS TO WIN,
SOMEONE THAT'S LIKE,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
I MIGHT NOT BE
GREAT AT THIS,
BUT I'M-A CONQUER
THIS DAMN THING."
RIGHT NOW NEITHER OF YOU
LOOK LIKE MODELS.
NEITHER OF YOU EVEN LOOK
LIKE MODELS IN THE MAKING.
YOU BOTH FAILED
MISERABLY.
WE CAN'T SEND
TWO OF YOU HOME,
'CAUSE MAYBE ONE OF YOU
WANTS IT
A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN THE OTHER.
ANN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU, TOCCARA.
Toccara: THANK YOU.
- Janice: GOOD LUCK, TOCCARA.
- Nolé: GOOD LUCK, TOCCARA.
Toccara: BYE, MAMA!
Amanda: YOU'RE SO AWESOME.
Toccara:
BYE, GUYS. WORK IT!
Toccara: I HONESTLY BELIEVE
THAT I SHOULD BE HERE
FOR THE FINAL THREE,
BUT I'M PROUD OF MYSELF.
I'M THE LARGEST GIRL
TO GET HERE,
AND I MADE IT THIS FAR.
SOMEONE HAS TO START
TO BREAK THE BARRIER,
SO HOPEFULLY THE NEXT PLUS-SIZED
GIRL THAT COMES ALONG--
SHE MAKES IT
A LITTLE BIT FURTHER.
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
BUT I'M JUST GRATEFUL THAT
MAYBE I MADE A PATH
FOR SOMEONE ELSE.
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Yaya: AM I SAYING
THESE THINGS TO BE COCKY?
Tyra: YAYA'S WINNING STREAK
BECOMES AN ISSUE IN THE HOUSE.
Norelle: JUST BECAUSE
YOU WON THREE CHALLENGES
DOESN'T MEAN
YOU'RE GONNA WIN,
AND I DON'T THINK IN ANY WAY
IS THAT AN ADVANTAGE.
Tyra: THEN THERE'S A CLASS
WITH AN ACTOR TO DIE FOR...
Eva: TAYE DIGGS!
Tyra: AND A NURSE WITH
A SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT.
PACK YOUR BAGS, GIRLS,
'CAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO...
Women: AAH!